next from the grounds of the
Gaithersburg City Hall Neil Irwin talks
about the financial crisis okay welcome
everybody welcome to the 4th annual
gaithersburg book festival I'm Nancy
Floreen I'm a member of the Montgomery
County Council and if you live in
Montgomery County I represent you if
you're visiting welcome to our fair
County I Gaithersburg is a vibrant
diversity that celebrates and supports
the arts and humanities and they're
really pleased to bring you this event
free of charge thanks to the generous
support of sponsors here so please visit
them they're scattered all around the
venue here and please say thanks and if
you can spend some money in our fair
city even better a few quick notes if
you have a device that makes the noise
please turn it off and please help us by
filling out the online survey about this
event your thoughts are really important
to us so please take the time and fill
one out if you do you'll be entered in a
drawing for really cool new anouk
ereader and also I'd like to remind you
of the Washington Independent Review of
Books upcoming writers and readers
conference call books alive there are
flyers for this out here this is going
to be on jun 8 that the north bethesda
marriott conference center you'll have
the chance to put your book to at least
two literary agents in here for some
great editors and authors like Alice
McDermott and George pelicanos
information is available on the
Washington Independent Review of Books
website and on their booth here which is
straight back Neil Irwin our featured
author will be signing books immediately
after this presentation and copies of
his book The Alchemist here we I've got
my own are for sale at the politics and
prose 10
since 2000 Neil Irwin has been a
journalist with the Washington Post he's
a graduate of st. Mary's College in
Maryland where he's a member of their
board of trustees he was a fellow and
economic and business journalism at
Columbia from which he has an MBA most
importantly though he covered the
federal reserve for the post all during
the financial crisis that at least
according to the book really started in
2007 and frankly we hope that crisis is
over now this book is great buy this
book all right this is really I the
untold story of how the world works and
most people don't follow this stuff but
let me tell you follow the money you
know for me of course as politicians
think we have something to do with that
to love us or tate us our tax policies
our spin policies are pretty clear and
understandable and of course it's easy
to blame us for whatever is going wrong
in the economy if it suits you you can
vote us out of office but really if you
follow the money according to neil irwin
book The Alchemist it's essential banks
of the world and their unelected leaders
that make the truly important decisions
I through highly complex strategies they
control how the money flows and how well
economies function and frankly how well
the voting public is doing when was the
last time you voted for remember the
board of governors of the Federal
Reserve not Anil urban's book is really
a fascinating account of how these
central banks the federal our Federal
Reserve being the Big Kahuna if you
asked me established monumental monetary
policies is dealt with the international
markets over the years and probably kept
us all from really major turmoil luckily
for everyone the world is too big to
fail on a personal note as a person of
Swedish descent I love that the first
central bank started in Sweden and
frankly I'm tempted
put in a bill requiring that all books
about history have a timeline just like
yours it's really terrific and with that
I'll turn it over to mr. early thank you
so much Nancy and I'm so excited to be
here at the Gaithersburg Book the
gaithersburg book festival which is a
bit of a mouthful and thanks so much for
your interest in the book so this is
twenty dollars you can use this to to
buy a couple of tickets to a movie you
can buy a hot meal you can take it over
there and buy a book if you like but why
you know it's just a piece of paper
doesn't have much going for it well it
has the Treasury Secretary signature
here but the but the really important
part is here on the top where it says
federal reserve note what makes this
money what makes this something that you
can use to buy the things you want to
need is that the Federal Reserve and
they're building down on Constitution
Avenue in Washington eight times a year
a group of economists and bank
regulators they sit around and decide
how much money they're going to pump
into or suck out of the US economy
they're the one who make it legal tender
who make it something you can use to buy
the things you need now there's a
simpler way to put that which I do in
the book and it's a bit of an
oversimplification but not all that much
that piece of paper I was just holding
up has is worth twenty dollars and can
buy a couple of tickets to a movie or a
hot meal or a book because Ben Bernanke
says it will you know what what we often
think of is as the the power in society
and what drives economies obviously it's
the labors of millions of people around
the country but the the financial system
the system of money is what creates the
bedrock that allows all that to happen
that the platform on which it stands now
that raises an interesting question how
did that come to be why is Ben Bernanke
and that those words federal reserve
note why does that matter and why is
that what makes that money valuable and
for that as Nancy alluded to we have to
do a little bit of history so I'll give
you a very brief history of what central
banks are how they came to exert this
great power over the world this great
powers over society so as mentioned
1650s Sweden have to go way back now
Sweden was a was an emerging power at
the time did control to a great
i er now if you consider controlling
most of Scandinavia and a little bit of
the Ukraine great they were great empire
they were on the rise now as in most of
Europe at the time their money was was
based on metal metal was the way you
bought goods and services now in most of
Europe that was gold or silver and in
Sweden I they had more copper so they
used copper as their money and they had
these giant copper plates they're about
this big weight about 40 pounds they
were held on the bank tellers backs now
you can see the problem they're having
big copper plates is not a terribly
efficient way to conduct Commerce if you
want to go to the store it does not it's
not come in very handy they needed a
system of having money out in their
economy that could be more efficient and
that's where the first central banker
comes in and and here I'll give you a
little preview the first central banker
was a pretty shady guy when you get down
to it he was born named Hans wit Macker
in Latvia he moved to Amsterdam where he
learned the banking businesses a young
man spent some time in a debtors prison
and then he got out of prison and
reinvented himself he moved to Sweden he
changed his name to Johan palm struck
now and we don't quite know what this
what the Swedish king knew about all
that at the time because doing
background checks was really hard in the
1650s but but Johan palm struck
established himself in Swedish society
and we don't even know really what he
looks like or what his personality was
but I can only guess that he was
somebody who instilled confidence that
he seemed like a completely credible
sober-minded serious person that the
elite of this of this country in the
1600s thought yeah we're going to trust
that guy with our money supply so Johan
pumps regatta got a license from the
crown from the from the royalty tube to
start what became stock homes Banco it
was the first central bank and it
started out simple people would take
their plates deposit in the bank they
would get they would get notes paper
notes and what they realized pretty
quickly is well wait a minute why why it
should we only give out notes equal to
the amount of money the amount of copper
we have in these vaults why don't we why
don't we actually make loans with this
actually do something with these reserve
because not everybody needs their big
copper plates at the same time so what
these notes became was the first paper
money in Europe and and it created a
boom suddenly you could go to the bank
and you could use your your estate as
collateral or your inventories of your
business as collateral and get these
paper notes that were unconnected from
the firm the amount of copper in the in
the bank the economy boomed things seem
to be going well until suddenly there
was a devaluation in the in the in the
dollar the big copper plates and
everybody at once said you know I think
I want my copper plate after all and
they showed up at the bank um so you've
seen it's a wonderful life I like to
imagine that Johan palm struck was kind
of like George Bailey no you don't
understand I don't have your money it's
tied up in ms Chris mrs. Christensen's
state it's tied up in mr. Nielsen's
Swedish pickled herring inventory I
don't have your money now you can see
why people were not very happy with this
what happened was ultimately a collapse
of the bank and Anna collapse in the
Swedish economy it did not end very well
for Johan plumstruck he was brought
before court sentenced to death the
sentence was commuted but he died a
couple years later anyway it was not the
most prideful most is not a history for
to start central banking that I think
many people would would look to as a as
a sweeping success but they did invent
something very important in Sweden in
the 1650s which is the idea that money
can be paper and money is not so much a
physical object if it's in a vault it's
an idea it's a way of keeping track in
the economy and and and that's why i
call this book The Alchemist around that
same time you had you had these people
in across Europe and in the Arab world
as well who were trying through all
kinds of methods to try and turn base
metals to Trenton 10 or ordinary
materials into gold and silver they you
know some were great scientist Sir Isaac
Newton it's been said was not the first
modern scientist he was the last of the
alchemists some were hooked hucksters
and frauds and and people who didn't
have much much going for them but the
truth is what what the experience of
Johan palm struck in stock homes Banco
proved in the 1660s is that you don't
need potions and magic and all kinds of
elaborate chemistry to try and create
gold earned money where there was none
what you need is a central bank with a
printing press and the authority of the
state to create value to create money
and and that became a model that one by
one the countries of the advanced world
started developing and started start
putting in place so that was the first
not terribly prideful not terribly
exciting story of where search Winx came
from it's been a long learning process
since then over the last three hundred
years and not always not always
successful so one one moment that a lot
of the modern central bankers look back
to as the 1860s 1866 the Bank of England
once again written the Great Empire you
know we think of all the reasons the
British the British Empire controlled
much of the globe one overlooked one is
the power of the British financial
system in the 19th century what the
British banking system was able to do
was funnel the savings of millions
millions of farmers Merchants all across
England all across Britain through the
City of London through the financial
sector right in the centre of london in
two major investments that fueled in the
industrial revolution one person can't
really easily come by the money to build
a massive textual factory or underwrite
a shipping voyage to india or hong kong
but but banks by taking the savings of
everyone and funneling it towards these
long lasting investments were able to do
that now the bank of england which was
great not too long after after the
sweetest central bank was a key part of
that financial system so there's a
there's a story that that gets told a
lot Mannion Walter Paget was was the
19th century editor of The Economist and
he wrote a book on this incident that
happened in 1866 there was a bank called
over and in gurnee it resembles if you
read the history a little like wachovia
or Bank of America these banks that ran
into trouble during the recent crisis in
the sense that they were they were both
a bank that had its roots in the
countryside of England that got into
high finance came to the city of london
and was a major major force so over and
gurney went under one day they tacked a
piece of paper to the door saying sorry
guys were closed for business I the
actual language in the book and and a
run had began suddenly suddenly no one
had faith if / and could go under what's
to stop the next Bank on the street on
Lombard Street in the city of london
from going on
so you had this wave of panic where
suddenly assets that would be completely
normally traded freely in normal times
they're called discount bills nobody had
trust that that they that they would
maintain their value and the flow of
Commerce shut down in the City of London
so the Bank of England stepped in and
said well our role is to be the lender
of last resort we are going to stand
here and any collateral that would be
good in normal times we'll take it and
we'll give you a short-term loan in
exchange we're going to keep the flow of
money happening in this economy come
hell or high water that's what the Bank
of England did well for budget wrote a
book about it and that established some
of the doctrine of what central bankers
have been doing for the 200 years since
you're the lender of last resort you
lend freely at a penalty rate you you
stand ready to to make money available
when it is otherwise not now it's not a
progress of for the good and when you
look at this history a lot of you
probably know the story of the 1920s and
what happened in via our German II this
is a power that central makers used and
they have sometimes misused so this is a
prime example it's at Verdun World War
One there's these huge reparations
payments the German government supposed
to make and and the men in Rudolph Ben
Havenstein was the was the central
banker for Germany in the early 1920s
and he saw it as his patriotic duty to
print money however much was needed to
fund the government so it can meet its
obligations now you can imagine how that
story ends when you just print print
print without regard to what's happening
to the price level it becomes an
inflationary force and then Havenstein
had this odd obsession with the physical
technical job of printing enough money
so he was very proud of this capacity
they had to print print to billions of
reichsmarks and distribute them out to
the country they its you know the
stories from that time or there there's
a million of them but you know you
needed a wheelbarrow to go to the
grocery store and buy your groceries
basically the the mark went from four to
a dollar the beginning of in the end of
1919 to four point two trillion to the
dollar in 1923 now what we also learned
from from that history is not just that
if you print too much money there will
be inflation and that'll be very
destabilizing but that that high
inflation is destabilizing to a society
as well
it was the very week that that the buy
more hyperinflation peaked and they
would soon bring in a new more credible
central banker and and and end it that
very week the beer hall the Munich Beer
help you sh the young Adolf Hitler led
in in trying to come to glory and come
to power it's it's very much the case
that when central bankers fail societies
fail now that's all the more true about
10 years later in the in the early 1930s
and this amounts to the greatest failure
of the global central bankers that that
is that history is seen you know the
stock market crash in 1929 in the United
States what's you know the kind of thing
that happens fairly often stocks go down
there's no reason that should have
caused a global catastrophe there's no
reason that u.s. stock markets dropping
twenty percent should lead to the German
economy of collapsing or the British
economy collapsing the reason it did
central bankers of that era didn't have
a proper common understanding of what
their obligations are to to each other
to the world to to society they were so
committed to staying on the gold
standard to stay in keeping the price of
their currency peg to gold and not doing
the steps they would take to support
their banking system that that a
deflationary spiral set in and and the
entire gears of commerce shut down so
it's been a checkered history but over
the last 70 years i think the the
central bankers have spent a lot of time
a lot of effort trying to learn from
those experiences trying to apply
analytical tools to come up with better
answers for how to guide the economy and
guide guide the future of the world by
2005 they thought they had pretty much
figured it out to be honest um you know
I in the in that this kind of historical
section of my book by looking at at the
2005 Jackson Hole conference this is an
event that happens every year in August
in injection hole wyoming the central
bankers the world come together and they
they talk they exchange big ideas this
was alan greenspan's last year's Federal
Reserve Chairman and there was a sense
in that room in 2005 that the world's
the great mysteries of the world economy
have been solved we know how to deal
with this we know how to fix this yeah
Japan is a bit of a mess but European
Europe has become more unified and is
peaceful and prosperous US economy is
doing great yeah there's some bubbles
building here and there may be housing
is something to watch maybe maybe
certain credit markets
a little out of whack but you know what
we've got this we've after it all this
long history we solved the mystery of
how to how to corral these forces that
have caused booms and busts over the
over the course of history um well let's
fast-forward to August ninth 2007 this
was a day you know this about a year
before what most of us think of as the
crisis but for the central bankers this
was really the beginning point it was a
Thursday jean-claude trichet was the
governor of the President of the
European Central Bank he was on vacation
and st. Milou on the Breton coast of
France phone rings about seven thirty in
the morning is Francesco papa dia the
head of the markets desk of the ECB in
Frankfurt mr. Shaye's as we have a
problem so the problem was that the
major European banks had had lost faith
in each other so they had lent very
heavily they bought a lot of the
subprime mortgage securities in the u.s.
those were all on their books and those
securities turns out we're not worth
what people thought they were things
that were triple-a turned out not to be
at all triple-a so what happened is they
weren't sure how much loss what degree
of losses they had incurred they weren't
sure what the other guys had incurred so
if you if the bank down the street is
you you know they have a lot of subprime
mortgages you don't want to lend the
money because you don't you're not sure
how bad it might be so the interbank
funding markets shut down and suddenly
normally a deutsche bank would lend
happily to BNP Paribas the French banks
would lend to the British banks in the
Swiss banks it's a very free-flowing
market that day on Thursday august nine
2007 that was shutting down and mr.
Trichet of the European Central Bank and
his colleagues had to decide what to do
about it it said what gather the
Executive Board they got a conference
call going now the European habit of
taking long August vacations made it a
little bit tricky people were in
different villas and resorts and in
Greece in Italy and Switzerland but they
were able to get everybody on the phone
and they decide what to do they said we
are the lender of last resort when banks
will not lend to each other we will step
in and be that source of funding it's
essentially what what the Bank of
England did in 1866 for modern age so
they they decided to create a facility
and and say we're going to offer you all
the money you want fixed-rate full
allotment here's our interest rate if
you need money
come and get it 49 banks took 95 billion
euros that day same day across the
English Channel in London I man in
Mervyn King the governor of the Bank of
England also had a day off that day he
was also on vacation he was going to
watch cricket at the kennington oval in
South London and he had told his his
staff don't call me unless it's an
emergency I I'm ready to have a day off
so that created a bit of a situation
they first had to decide well is this a
big enough deal that we're going to
interrupt the governor's vacation they
said yes it was they called him fairly
soon but there's actually a kind of a
metaphor there that the Mervyn King was
was off the cricket match that day in
the sense that he and the Bank of
England and now those early days of the
crisis they felt like well you know what
these banks bought all these bad
securities that's their problem they
need to suffer the consequences of their
bad decisions let's sit back and let
them let them deal with it themselves
for now been giving them those early
days was was more hands-off than than
the ECB or the Federal Reserve same day
August night 2007 Ben Bernanke wakes up
in his house on Capitol Hill and is
driven to to his breakfast meeting at
730am with Hank Paulson the Treasury
secretary he's in a black Cadillac
driven by the Federal Reserve Police by
the way it's nice to have your own
police force you can go through traffic
lights so so Ben Bernanke's on his way
to his meeting with Hank Paulson gets an
email from men named Dave Skidmore who
is in the Federal Reserve's Public
Affairs Office and this email says and
I'm paraphrasing hey I just thought you
should know got a call from from the sky
at Reuters apparently the ECB's doing
some dollar-denominated thing with with
the bush bank you know the Reuters guys
heading into the Treasury press room
early we'll see what this is so
translation the most powerful financial
policy maker in the world is learning
about this from a garbled message
ultimately from a Reuters reporter which
is a not not a great way to run a runner
railroad but but so brenneke has his
meeting with Hank Paulson they
eventually get more complete information
on what had happened what the Europeans
had done and what became the global mega
crisis had begun it was the first
intervention by central bank he was the
first unconventional step it was the
beginning of a story that I think we we
all know a little too well
you my little personal side of it about
a year after the events I was just
describing September 14th 2008 was a
Sunday I was the Federal Reserve
reporter for The Washington Post I had a
long few weeks because if you remember
the Fannie Mae Freddie Mac bailout was
the weekend before there'd been a lot of
stuff going on those few weeks I ain't
had a day off and forever summit ember
14th there was a there's a few days
before there was a cartoon in the
Financial Times saying please Hank take
a weekend off people wanted Hank Paulson
to take a weekend off and maybe not bail
anybody out that weekend September 14
2008 i was watching the washington
redskins play the new orleans saints
there's a one o'clock game and i get an
email in the first quarter from from a
source and email says hey are you in the
office and I respond should I be and
they they respond you might want to be
in the office so I respond can it wait
till halftime and the responses you
might want to be in the office that of
course is the day that that Lehman
Brothers was allowed to go into
bankruptcy it was also the day that the
bank of america bought merrill lynch it
was a day that Wall Street changed
forever now the events that followed in
those those ugly weeks of the fall of
two thousand eight they've been
chronicled in a lot of books and and and
i'm sure most was remember a good to the
history it's AIG it's the Tar Pits it's
all these ugly bailouts and all this
really economic calamity that was
happening at that time I'm going to
focus on a couple aspects you might not
know about that I think are very
important to understanding what this
response really was on a global level so
if in the if in the 1930s the central
bankers didn't understand each other
they didn't communicate with each other
they didn't act with common resolve that
had very much changed by 2008 and by the
time two thousand eight rolls around
there's very much a sense of common
purpose among these guys they they meet
many times a year six times a year they
go to Basel Switzerland to the bank for
international settlements they have two
days of meetings and long discussions of
economic forces they also have a dinner
that's kind of I call it the world's
most exclusive dinner party on the 18th
floor of the bis in Basel Switzerland
that's the most really intimate
opportunity for the leading central
bankers of the world to exchange ideas
to understand each other on a personal
level they eat delicious food they drink
good burgundy in Bordeaux the joke is
that they call it Gronk Ruby
is it's very good one so so by the time
we hit 2008 and that's and there's also
Jackson Hole which I mentioned there's
also all these international meetings
that happen seemingly every week one
central banker told me sometimes in
times of crisis I feel like I see each
other we see each other more than we see
our wives so with that sense of common
purpose how do they deploy that in 2008
well here's one aspect that I don't
think people pay much attention to it's
called swap lines the basic idea is
simple the European banks had all these
us dollar-denominated assets they had
you know the Jewish bank and although
German and French and Dutch banks had
spent all this money to buy to buy us
dollar-denominated assets but the ECB
cannot lend them dollars in a pinch so
when the interbank funding markets shut
down when they couldn't get money yet
dollars on the private markets they had
no way of getting the dollars they
needed so the ECB in the Federal Reserve
and the Swiss National Bank in the Bank
of England in the Bank of Canada they
came up with this arrangement where if
you're the ECB and you have your bank's
need dollars you go to the Fed and say
okay I need ten billion dollars you give
the Fed an equivalent amount of euros
that gives you the dollars you have
contract 90 days later you unwind the
whole thing the Fed makes some interest
money on it and then the ECB is able to
lend those those dollars out to European
banks now you know people pay attention
to the bailouts and stuff in 2008 AIG
was an 85 billion dollar bailout at the
peak these swap lines which extended all
over the earth added up to five hundred
and eighty billion dollars you know this
is kind of an untold story of how this
sense of trust of common purpose enabled
them to respond in a coherent
coordinated way to this crisis that
affected the world you know Allah so so
that was the most intense phase of
crisis then it was a calamity was
spreading in every market every part of
the world and it was Ben Bernanke
jean-claude trichet mervyn king who were
cutting interest rates they were
creating all these innovative ways to
pump money into the into the world
economy and it adds up to a wall of
money that essentially surrounded this
this crisis and said whatever however
bad it gets we have in our power this
bottomless capacity to create money and
we're going to stand and staunch the
tide and keep it from spiraling in
something worse
now since the crisis ended in in
2008-2009 that's not the end of the
story I think we all know if you didn't
already that that that was really only
the beginning of a much bigger story
it's a story that starts in subprime
mortgages and lehman brothers and all
those things from 2008 but spread into
Europe it spread into sovereign debt
Greece Ireland Spain it spread into
different corners the financial or the
European banking system the the world
trade system this was not a one-off
story of crisis response it's all over
and so that's what I try and do in the
book is tell this global story and all
these interrelated parts you know Warren
Buffett has a line you don't find out
who's naked until the tide goes out it
turns out the Greek government was was
was the naked one in this case the
crisis exposed some long-simmering
problems in their excessive borrowing
and and and bad governance that I think
we just didn't understand or didn't see
when things were going better and it was
this receding tide created by the crisis
the mega crisis that enabled us to see
as a world what was going wrong and
greasing some of the other European
nations debts um so so let's talk a
little bit about how that how that came
to be you know the European crisis it's
a hard thing to get your head around I
spent a couple years covering it I went
over there a good bit and and I still
feel like it's it's something that it's
not easy to get a good grasp of so I
start that story in in october two
thousand nine what happened is a new
government came to power the socialist
party in greece came to power three days
later after they won their elections the
new finance minister George Papa
constante knew was in a meeting with the
central bank governor in Greece George
provo polis they all all the important
people in the situation and George which
makes a little confusing so one George
said to the other George well you
there's something you need to know the
deficit this year is going to be a lot
bigger than we expected it's not nine or
ten percent of GDP it's thirteen or
fourteen percent of GDP the finance
minister just just took this job just
when the elections on a triumphant hi he
asked are you sure are you are you sure
because suddenly this grand agenda they
had had and they thought they would be
able to enact with these after winning
these elections it's not going to be
possible it was going to be a time
starrett ii and budget-cutting rather
than doing new things now the European
crisis i think is a challenging one as
an american understand because the the
political context in europe is messy and
different you know what we saw over and
over is the ECB in frankfurt is a
unified central bank it works very
effectively not unlike the Federal
Reserve but the government's you have 17
government in the eurozone they each
have their own incentives their own
political situations and that creates
some very trying times I remember one
when everybody in the world was worrying
about what Slovenia was going to do
slovenia is a country of 3 million
people but they're part of the eurozone
they had to approve this financial
stability fund if their Parliament did
not approve it who knows what
catastrophes could have resulted and so
we were all waiting on Slovenia that's
the unusual political context if you
think having a US Congress and having to
see what they do is a dysfunctional
system imagine if you had 17 of them to
to deal with that's that has been the
consistent challenge of Europe over the
last few years and one that I that I
tell about in the book so so you know in
Europe you have this situation where
there are a number of governments that
had large deficits markets were turning
on them so the question is what do you
what do you do if you're a central bank
well in the US you could have a monetary
policy you could have a set of policies
that Thun to the US economy problem in
Europe is the Greek economy the Spanish
economy they're very different
situations from the German or French
economies as a result you don't have
that tool monetary policy to allow these
adjustments that is these imbalances
that have been building up over a decade
you didn't have a way for those two you
didn't have a pressure valve that would
allow those two to escape um so the
adjustments that in the past would have
happened by Greece devalue its currency
and then there's some inflation and
people are less wealthy but suddenly
their economy can get back on track from
there that pressure valve did not exist
so you had to have that same force
happen through different measures and
that became the troika so the European
Central Bank the International Monetary
Fund and the european commission would
come together in greece then Ireland and
Portugal to say okay here's the things
you have to do to receive this aid and
these are very detailed documents long
documents oh you may need to make these
reforms to your pension system you have
to make these reforms to your health
care procurement
you know it's it's kind of it was the
the least bad option for these countries
but it's also a very unusual moment you
have these unelected officials in in
Frankfurt who are essentially dictating
here's what you're going to do on your
pension system on your on your health
care system on your privatization of the
electric utilities and everything else
so that's one prime example of where the
kind of democratic questions that arise
from this great power exerted by the
central bankers is is that it's at its
most extreme anytime your central bank
is dictating what you're going to do on
your pensions something's gone wrong in
the world so one more one more story I
want to kind of tell and help
characterize what this what this saga
has been quantitative easing so we get
through the darkest phase of the crisis
2008-2009 and you find yourself in an
economy that's really not very good at
all US economy through 2009 2010 it
starts growing starts recovering in the
summer 2009 but doesn't feel like much
of a recovery it's not rapid growth it's
not enough to make up the lost ground
from the recession it's just kind of
plodding along and that's the kind of
recovery we've had ever since then so
you get to the summer of 2010 and and
there's a decision to make for the Fed
for Ben Bernanke and the Federal Reserve
growth was very slow in fact there was
some evidence who might have been
slipping back into a double-dip
recession that summer of two thousand
ten an inflation is quite low so the Fed
aims for about two percent inflation
every year they want prices to rise
generally about two percent it was
running more like 11.2 percent in that
summer of two thousand ten and the
thinnest decide well we already have
interest rates at zero we've had in this
race in zero since december of 2008 do
we do more do we come up with something
we can do to pump more money into the
economy increase the money supply get
inflation up toward 2% get to hopefully
get growth growth on track and the
answer they come up with is quantitative
easing so what that means is all right
we're the Fed we're going to we already
have our target for short-term interest
rates at zero but we're going to go and
buy longer-term bonds we're going to
essentially create money out of thin air
by billions and billions of dollars
worth of bonds and that money will be
out in the economy and that will help
help help the markets in the economy
recover
now it's it's funny you know we think of
this process of creating money as a
mysterious thing and you might think
it's kind of a grand scene or something
grandiose I've actually I've actually
seen how they do it I was actually in
the room at the Federal Reserve Bank of
New York where they carried out
quantitative easing and it's and it's
pretty unimpressive to tell you the
truth what here's here's what it looks
like you go then on a Tuesday morning
little conference room no bigger than
this stage a little bit in the stage and
and you have three guys at a computers
on one wall behind them you have a
supervisor kind of watching everything
you have a tech person in case the
computers break maybe a more senior
manager will stop by most days you have
a CNBC going on the on the wall you have
a digital clock you have Bloomberg
terminals ago your financial data and
they say okay well today we're going to
buy three billion dollars worth of bonds
so they go in the market they let all
the primary dealers these are the 19
largest largest banks in the world or
that are have this official relationship
with the new york fed and say okay we're
looking to buy three billion dollars for
the bonds what do you have for us and
they make offers it could be for their
clients it could be themselves but they
say all right we have this bond will
will sell it to you at this price it's a
reverse auction process they find the
price that which they can hit their
three billion dollar number and click
the click what just happened is three
billion dollars that did not previously
exist is on the books of those banks and
those bombs are on the books of the New
York Fed it's all over before lunch
takes about 45 minutes that entire
process to happen and like I say it's a
surprisingly kind of banal a little room
now this is a this is what you do if
you're trying to pump money to the
economy but what we found over these
last few years is these unconventional
ways of doing monetary policy of trying
to support growth are not as effective
as as the normal tools so the Fed is now
done more than two trillion dollars
they're doing 85 billion dollars a month
right now in an additional easing trying
to buy more bonds and it hasn't you know
it's been enough to keep us away from
deflation we haven't had falling prices
like the Japanese have had for the last
20 years we haven't had you know a
double dip into recession but we also
haven't had the kind of robust growth
that everybody is trying to get so the
question is are they at the end of their
Road have they done everything they can
or or are we out of tools and I think
what we've seen out of the bernanke fed
this last few years
is a is a real capacity to to look
around and say okay what's working
what's not it's not working we're going
to dust off the playbook and try
something new and that's what they've
been doing since sep tember with
communications so they said in starting
in September and then December all right
we're not just going to buy all these
bonds we're also going to use
communications we're going to tell you
what we're going to do and it's this
we're going to try and keep pumping
money into the economy until we're on
track we're going to keep interest rates
very low until either unemployment drops
to six and a half percent or inflation
becomes a problem and get sub up two and
a half percent they're trying to use
communications and a sense that you know
this is the plan to instill confidence
in the economy and get growth on track
so far there's some evidence the
economy's doing a little better this
year but it's it's pretty modest now the
question is what does all this activism
that all the global central banks have
been doing for the last five years
what's the cost and what's what are the
risks this creates well you know the
truth is we have been an uncharted
territory and this true for nearly six
years now and you know inevitably the
kinds of things that are being done now
that involve these trillions of dollars
of taxpayer dollars euros yen everything
else you know there there could be
consequences we don't fully understand I
don't know what they'll be so far
inflation has been a problem will that
change one day well it certainly could
could asset bubbles emerged that are
really really problematic you know
stocks have been rising a lot the last
couple years is that you know that's a
good thing if you have a 401k at some
point do they get beyond fundamentals
and create a new new risk of bubbles
right now I think some of the corporate
bond markets the junk bond market
actually does look a little bubbly the
question is do they have the tools and
capacity to deal with this on the back
end and i think the real thing to worry
about is not that is not that it'll be
beyond the feds capacity to deal with
future inflation but political will so
let's say that some of these predictions
of inflation come out turn out to be
true in a couple years will the future
fed presumably it's not pretending
anymore but but whoever's the Chairman
then will he or she have the the resolve
the ability and the courage to say all
right party's over now is the time to
start tightening the money supply and
and prevent this problem that's that's
the problem they face at the same time I
think you know my taken and I think
you'll see in the book is ultimately
you know it's it's unnerving in a
democracy to have this small group of
people who exert this vast power who
deploy trillions of dollars and euros
and pounds on behalf of the public who
aren't elected it's certainly troubling
as a reporter I like to believe in
transparency and and people being clear
about what they're doing and not lurking
in the dark shadows of you know of a
building in Basel Switzerland at the
same time again and again what we've
seen this last six years is that these
were the guys who had the the capacity
and the will to act on a speed and on a
scale commensurate to the crisis so at a
time that democratic institutions moved
slowly with haltingly moved to
cautiously it was central bankers who
had the ability and the power to to use
their bottomless ability to print money
to to deal with the crisis as it
unfolded so I think it is troubling from
a democratic perspective that this is
how it's happened but I also think it's
been better than the in the alternative
and something that that you know we we
we certainly can be grateful to Ben
Bernanke anas colleagues for keeping
things from getting worse you know it's
it's not that it's not that this is a
great economy this is a very difficult
environment unemployment still close to
eight percent that's not anything to be
proud of but when you look at history
and you look at the grand sweep the
grand arc of history of what can go
wrong when central bankers do not
respond on a scale commensurate with the
with the scale of the disaster how bad
things can get in short a catastrophe
averted is is no small thing but you
know the Fed has a three trillion dollar
balance sheet that's essentially your
money that is uh those are taxpayer
resources I think it's all the more
important given this activism given all
that they've been doing that we all pay
attention and ask those hard questions
there are mechanisms for accountability
journalism and and what people report
and what I do is one of them another is
Congress been ranked egos before
Congress he's doing it this coming
Wednesday in fact and I think for our
lawmakers to ask those hard questions
and make sure that we as we as a society
understand what they're doing and why
and what the risks are and hold them
accountable if they if they get it wrong
I think that's one of the most important
things we can do in this world where
they're deploying this vast power on
behalf of all of us so that is my take
and that is a story The Alchemist hope
you if you read the book and enjoy it
and would love to answer your questions
or hear your thoughts sorry if you could
get some questions please do it at the
mic in the back
from what i read this austerity that has
been pushed by Congress has been
debunked the study was absolutely wrong
and I don't know whether Bernanke has
the power or the will to come out and
say no this is not the time for
austerity we need to spend federal
dollars in order to get an employed
populous you're never going to you're
never going to lower employment unless
the feds who can print money start
printing it and hiring and hopefully
replicate what happened during the
Depression years can he speak out or is
it an unwillingness that's interesting
um you know it's funny there's almost
been two conversations over the last few
years on austerity and and when to cut
deficits when you're in a when you have
large deficits one view that is pretty
widely held is is the austere Ian view
we need austerity now if you have large
deficits you have to reduce them that
will instill confidence that will that
will in turn create growth and it's just
what we have to do that was what drunk
la cliche in Europe argued that's been
the policy pursued by Europe's been the
policy really pursued by Britain as well
as you allude to that is not looking
like a good set of solutions the
European economy still disaster the
British economy has been stagnant for
three years and and even one of the
studies that provided some of the
intellectual foundations for that idea
that said oh if you get debt over ninety
percent of GDP then then you'll have
lower growth there were some some major
methodological flaws in that study from
Carmen Reinhart and Ken Rogoff what's
amazing is how on the other side of that
debate you have pretty good consensus so
you know Paul Krugman is is the most
visible and and and and very aggressive
and assertive in his way of writing
about it but I think the truth is where
Krugman is and where say Ben Bernanke is
where Libya blonde shard of the the
International Monetary Fund where a lot
of the mainstream economists at the big
banks at the big forecasting firms
they're not so different they might be
different in tone and how they talk
you're definitely going to hear Ben
Bernanke talked the way Paul Krugman
dozens columns on Capitol Hill next week
but on substance they're not as far
apart as you might think and and I think
actually Bernanke has been consistently
in this last couple years been a voice
of caution in telling Congress yes we
need to worry about long-term debts and
and entitlements and folks on those
long-term issues that could make our
economy more competitive but in the
short run there's a lot of risk if you
cut too fast got too far too fast you
can suck the wind out of growth we saw
actually in the last Federal Reserve
policy statement just a few weeks ago
they explicitly said fiscal policy has
been a headwind growth um so I think the
widespread view in the within the
federal reserve and from Ben Bernanke is
that look we're doing everything we can
here we're trying to deploy all this
money don't mess it up Congress and and
what we've had is actually a pretty
surprising degree of deficit reduction
so we were ten percent of deficits GDP
five years ago or four years ago in 2009
we're going to be about five percent
this year we're going to be about two or
three percent to 2015 so that's been a
pretty rapid pace of deficit reduction
it's come about because of because of
the expanding economy the fiscal cliff
tax increases the the debt ceiling
negotiations involve spending cuts I
think what you'll see on as bernanke
goes to Congress this week and in the
future is he will be very polite about
it but he will say watch it guys this is
this is too much budget cutting too fast
this in dangers our economy
yeah um I understand that there's no not
much of any regulation on some of these
economic toys you know like derivatives
and I guess there's a lot of others that
I don't know about but i was i was
wondering is there any protection
against the common man against some of
these inventions of high high finance
yeah i think if there's one thing we
learned from this this entire episode
the last several years is is how help
unimaginably complex the system has
become and and how much that complexity
can endanger the rest of us can endanger
the entire economy in the world I mean I
can't tell you in 2007 2008 2009 it
seems like every week I was learning of
some new corner of the financial system
the financial markets that that I had
never heard of before and I mean I you
know I wrote about this stuff I have an
MBA I was thought I knew a lot about how
the financial markets worked and it
turns out there were all these corners
of the financial markets I had never
heard of and even a lot of the
regulators were not as fully verse as
you might expect so I mean one small
example there are these things called
sieve structured investment vehicles in
the back in two thousand seven that were
essentially a way for for the big banks
to create a kind of shadow bank on the
side that technically wasn't on their
balance sheet but they ended up
guaranteeing anyway and those that was
one of the early earliest phases of this
crisis was those those imploded and and
endangered a lot of the big banks I
think the lesson here is that is that we
need better financial supervision and
question is do we now have that so the
dodd-frank act gave regulators a lot
more power to have windows into into the
banks into other institutions can they
use it properly to top us avoid this
fate in the future and you know one
example so AIG bailed out by taxpayers
80 85 billion dollars was essentially
regulated by nobody before that it was
technically the office of Thrift
Supervision for some reason but as a
practical matter this is the world's
biggest insurer no federal regulators
really understanding what they were
doing what risks they were taking and
what they might poach the rest of us
under dodd-frank now the now the
financial stability Oversight Committee
can say okay you mr. insurance company
or miss
you know non-bank lender you are
systemically important so you're going
to regulate by the Fed just like
Citigroup and JPMorgan there's new
office of financial research in the
Treasury Department that's charged with
finding new ways of pulling out
statistics to understand where risks are
building up now we'll all that be enough
do the regulator's now have enough
information and enough ways into
understanding what risks are building
the system I sure hope so because if not
we haven't learned anything but but if
if they fail it's not for lack of trying
it's it's because the sheer complexity
of what the financial system is doing is
really hard to keep track of so when I
was wondering what the reaction of the
bankers has been to your book uh it's
you know like it's interesting the so
I'm I'll be honest I'm pretty tough on
Mervyn King in this book the governor of
the Bank of England it's clear they are
they're not happy the Bank of England
with the book Mervyn King is interesting
character he's a brilliant economist he
actually was a shared an office suite
with Ben Bernanke at MIT in the early
1980s but he's also he has sharp elbows
he rubs a lot of his colleagues the
wrong way can be a little imperious and
and and and tough and getting his ways
so he has a lot of enemies in British
politics from the Bank of England I tell
some of those stories from different
colleagues of his complaining about his
manner over the years and how he kind of
seemed rolled them so it's clear the
bank of england is not terribly happy
the rest is not much I can say but you
know it's it's funny you try and tell a
story and try and turn this five years
of history into a into a narrative that
makes sense and and hopefully they can
at least respect what what it does which
is try and take this really complex
stuff they've been doing for six years
across three continents and turned into
a single narrative that that makes sense
for people who don't understand the
inner workings monetary policy which
most people don't
thank you for your talk to you sorry I'm
just one question which i think is
pretty quick how do you how do you think
that we reconcile these issues with the
fact that of those 19 banks that you
mentioned many of them don't affect
serve american interests and if you can
also kind of no job to try to weave in
that the confluence of those those
overseas interests with the fact that
the Federal Reserve is actually private
and not really a federal entity yeah so
um so first on that last point on the
photos are being private that's not
that's not exactly right so that's what
a lot of people say that it is true that
the Reserve Bank's the 12 Reserve banks
around the country technically are owned
by the banks that that are in their
district and that they regulate that's
more of an accounting convention than a
than our reality you know the Federal
Reserve Board is a government agency in
Washington and you know its leaders are
appointed by the President and confirmed
by the Senate they you know that's it's
a government agency like any other it's
covered by boy it's covered by all that
kind of stuff the Reserve Bank's are a
little more strange that's kind of a
weird hybrid structure their profits all
our return to share to taxpayers so when
they when New York Fed makes money off
of all these programs that money gets
returned to taxpayers they're actually
having record earnings lately because of
all this money printing so about leave
90 billion dollars last year so you know
but it is a strange structure where the
presidents of those Reserve Banks they
are they are chosen by a board of
directors that includes a lot of local
business people and then they have to be
confirmed you know approved by the by
the Fed board in Washington it's a
really a wheelie system I don't think
it's as simple as saying it's it's owned
by private interests but but I can see
why people would say that you know it is
clearly the case so the fact that
European banks were major holders of all
these American securities you know it's
amazing to think about but if you took
out a mortgage in 2005-2006 that was
that mortgage was very likely packaged
into a very complex security that that
then was sold to somebody and in a lot
of cases that somebody was a German bank
or a french bank or a dutch bank or a
Belgian bank
that created this global crisis in a way
that's that I think a lot of people
didn't understand the time and a lot of
those early steps by the Fed including
the swap lines i talked about including
some of these unconventional ways to
pump money into the banking system
really were about providing dollars of
those European banks so there's two ways
to look at that on the one hand this is
a this is US taxpayer resources you know
why is our money going to help European
banks the flip side of that is well the
European banks were the one supporting
the US economy and lending money to us
homeowners and other kinds of people
borrowing money in the u.s. so the
question is what's the alternative if
they not done that and the European
banking system it had imploded in 2007
2008 2009 would the US economy actually
be better off and I would argue no
because if those are the institutions
providing the capital from US mortgage
lending think about how much mortgage
lending froze up in that period imagine
how much worse would be if the European
banks were not able to keep keep buying
those securities so it's not an ideal
system as I say if you care about kind
of accountability and transparency it's
not good but but it may beat the
alternatives and with that I think you
all so very much for coming I'll be
signing books and just a bit
as mr. Berman said he will be signing in
the book's author signing tents over on
the other side of this tent over here
you can buy his book I think right here
in politics and prose if you need if you
want to get a copy of that and if you
have a chance if you could fill out the
survey which is on the gaithersburg book
festival website and thank you all for
coming on next it's a the last group
it's actually a panel today and they'll
be starting at about ten minutes thank
you all thank you
that was Neil Irwin live from the
gaithersburg book festival we'll have
more in just a couple of minutes
hey
take a look
is it